you've gotten to do a lot of cool things
because of who you are
rank how high on the list was going
backstage with your daughter to meet bts
that was up there that was seriously up
there i mean i i'd become a sort of bts
fan via
um
via her she'd sort of introduced me to
them
and um i had become like we watched a
lot of them on youtube so by the time we
went to see them in las vegas i kind of
was like genuinely a fan
and so meeting them was just
surreal because we walked into a room
and they were just stood there
just waiting for us to walk in and they
were absolutely lovely and um it was
extraordinary and i i was a little star
struck were they sure to like do they do
this with a lot of people do they have
any idea that they've seen sean of the
dead do you know what i mean well rm who
is the the probably the most adept
english speaker of the group although
they're all sort of like you know
getting better at speaking english um
he's bit of a movie fan and and he'd
gone to see baby driver with v another
one of the band um so he was aware of of
my work for sure and we had a little
chat about movies and stuff i i didn't
know if if the other guys had seen sean
of the dead or anything like that i mean
i presume they have um
but they were just really lovely it was
a nice moment
you